okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is an internal designer
view of sparkle and related graph store
functionality for a future version of
Wolfram language so let's get started so
Tony do you want to describe what the
what this all is here yes so the graph
store package is divided in three parts
one is the IRI which is a generalization
of the oil it is a basic building block
and then there's RDF which allows making
statements about resources the resources
that are identified by the IR eyes and
later their Sparkle with which you can
query RDF graphs okay so the example
here we have it's from wiki data the
first one is from Vicki data and the
other IR eyes use different vocabularies
like this in one Monday is from the
using the time ontology and the other
one uses schema.org vocabulary okay but
so these things have no particular
alignment with our whole world of I mean
that for example wiki data we have some
alignment with our entities is that true
[Music]
it is what we do I mean in in many
domains we have we have IDs for wiki
data and Wikipedia again we haven't we
haven't exposed those in a useful way
yet partly because we've talked about
external identifier or IRI and we also
met recently and several of us on this
calls looked at IRI and external
identifier but they're both fulfilling
some of the same function so we might
want to expose use IRI as the way of
exposing and looking up those going
between entities and identifiers but
that's something we should I don't I
don't think that's right I think IRI is
more specific than external identifier I
think extol identifier applies to lots
of kinds of things
have no sparkle anywhere in sight um and
I would think iri is a special case of
external identifiers that um you know
with certain special properties that are
relevant to the whole rdf sparkle type
world okay so let's take a look so I
mean can I ask it
there is simply haven't understood are
we are we playing to put this into the
system context so right now at least
from our last meetings the idea was that
we have a graph store context or maybe
under a different name I'm asking
because for SQL we're kind of in a
similar situation that we have developed
a layer that is not quite user facing
that it's closer to the SQL and and the
plan is just to expose it through and
restore yes well I think the same type
of thing is what we should imagine here
that there's some kind of craft store
mechanism that we expose where you know
it may happen there's an externally
sourced craft store just like it may
happen as is usually the case for the
SQL thing that I mean there you know the
world is full of SQL databases the world
is a lot less full of you know triple
stores yep so so one interesting
development is that one plan is to use
sparkle to query relational databases or
at least make it possible to do so mmm
by using our to our ml the mapping
language for relational databases 20th
and dead what's the what's the benefit
of that it's yet that the language is in
some sense different yeah and our native
query language is yet different again
and has you know lots of things that
that you know where we're making a big
effort to map kind of you know that the
strengths of our native query language
is much greater than
SQL but we're mapping you know we're
trying to understand how to slice off a
piece that is compatible with SQL
databases yes so yeah so before I forget
so the whole purpose of this meeting
should be that at some point we get to
this Park very language the last
meetings we have more talked about why
but I think that sparkle is a pretty
nice language that we should consider
yeah
carefully and you just 25 people in the
world I mean it's look there's a reason
that I mean you know there exist certain
externally exist you know external
triple stores that people are built you
know the question of should we take our
semantic relation framework for example
and make it into something like this is
very unclear to me very very unclear
I mean zooming out a little bit you know
I think it's it's interesting
to study what happens with these things
and it's good for us to have you know
the the the the three examples that will
always come up over and over again of
whether or triple stores sure it's nice
to be able to import those I'm slightly
you know there's a well okay the main
use the main use would be to ask sparkle
like queries against our own entity
stores
yeah well that I support but that needs
a rapper in the same way that we have
entity store wrapping SQL databases it's
something that makes complete sense and
also I mean there are other types of of
grant databases that are probably more
popular than Sparkle or or rather other
types of query languages that are more
popular than Sparkle nowadays and so I I
think that getting too close to spark
hole at least in the system
functionality would would be painting
ourselves into words yeah it's not the
right thing to do I mean okay
let's understand let's see what we can
learn from all of this and let's see
what functionality we can abstract from
it that is usable you know okay
there's probably in the end will be a
low-level thing that allows people who
are Sparkle enthusiasts to you know to
make use of those capabilities in our
system but the more interesting thing is
things that we can build on top of this
that actually fit properly into our
system so let's try to understand what
you've got here okay so I think I
understand these IR eyes
so let's let's take a look here what
what on earth is all this stuff so the
next thing is an example of an RDF graph
written in a symbolic form how do I see
the graph it's it's a tricky Chris
how to visualize RDF graph so there are
certain approaches and Bellator's here
and one of them this is the hyper graph
or is it a regular graph it's some sort
of hyper craft okay
so in order if you usually want to
describe resources using existing
vocabulary and what you see there for
instance banana is of type fruit and it
is one of the typical things to do first
you state water objects are that you
have and then you give a label for the
humans they want to need it yeah and you
can also import them that's one of the
possible formats turtle what you see
here and that's an example that we just
discussed internally what we mean having
an importer ttle importer sounds like a
fine thing but what's it gonna turn into
I mean this is it's awesome RDF graph
and the question that we are wondering
internally for instance is how can
okay
so this is a typical RDF triple consists
of if I'm seeing these triples here it's
a you know it's a thing a relational
thing absolutely correct
okay
I don't know what a Nadia plank node is
what is a nadia plank node so in the
graph you always have notes in every
position of the treble but some of them
don't have an identifier you just state
their existence and then you need to
link them to the other nodes in the
graph if you want that's why you give
them a label but this is not an
identifier
I wouldn't call a blank note what's that
100 them so maybe if if you look in the
input you see it a little bit better so
let's say if you want to say from God
yes okay literals are also some kind of
note but yeah they are distinguished
right so you know in in the I mean if I
meant to be a little bit snippy about it
the you know back in antiquity or
something you know Aristotle well people
you know decided that logic represents
everything in the world and this is now
a you know triples and this is related
to that represents everything in the
world um you know I'm not very convinced
it represents certain things just like
you know people could say well an SQL
database can represent everything in the
world which is again fairly not
convincing but look it's a definite kind
of thing it's a bunch of triples and I
understand and that's interesting and I
wish it had more obvious uses you know
beyond the fairly few examples that get
trotted out every time so to speak um
now you know
as you say well let's take a look down
here at these are the queries right yes
so before we imported some graphs or
constructed someone is the fruit graph
in order the person graph and here we
see what soon tax is one of the query
forms this sparkle select which returns
a list of solutions and these solutions
are basically bindings from variables to
your values in the graph oh and here in
the details section of sparkle select
you can see what are all the possible
patterns that you can form starting with
a triple pattern a basic graph pattern
and then recursively grouping any
pattern type filtering solutions having
optional parts of a pattern path and so
on I mean so here in this audio thing so
fundamentally what you're trying to do
is you're trying to instantiate these
the
kinds of things in
No
so there's a difference between the
already F blank notes and just about
sparkle variables so if you scroll down
a little bit if you see in the sparkle
query in the sparkle select yes there
the question mark yeah there is a
formatted version of a sparkle variable
those are instantiated
so you're basically trying to find a
match and in your check yeah right so
this is like our cases but but for you
know what we were discussing before
which I liked a lot better is trying to
understand from our symbolic expression
structures or our graph structures with
that matter how to put in you know
pattern variables yeah I investigated it
for quite some time and it turns out
that these variables in sparkle are
closer to what we have the quantity
variable that we have these are
basically things that appear in a
formula like in Formula data because
they can appear both on the left and on
the right hand side in some sense why
our patterns are more like for rules
where you have two full pattern on the
left and the name of the pattern on the
right hand side so these heartfelt
variables are closer to quantity
variable
or to algebraic variables which can
appear anywhere yes
but so you're essentially trying to
solve a graph equation of some kind that
says you know this sub graph you know
you're trying to figure out I mean I
think it's more like that
yes so what you have here in again in
this Park a select details section the
basic graph pattern that is the tricky
part and guess where you do some some
kind of sub graph making all the others
are built on top of that basic law which
one is the the second one here no one
one above just a basic graph pattern
yeah
the others are defined recursively in
terms of joins for instance
so here's an interesting example that we
try to model using entities and it's a
little bit tricky to boot like that but
quite naturally using sparkle like
asking what are all the all the
important now davonne above the query
above no give me for some company all
the CEOs of and together with the year
that is pretty tricky to formulate using
entity queries but it is pretty easy to
read and to write using stock
I guess I mean we've never tried to
build out things like this in terms of
entity queries
look I mean for the 25 people who know
how to write sparkle queries this is
great I you know I just don't think it's
a you know it's very different situation
from SQL for example where there are
millions of people who know how to write
SQL queries so one thing I noticed is
that when writing sequel queries if you
go along relations you usually start
nesting the joins and these nested
expressions get pretty deep and then
it's difficult to modify them while in
sparkle you just keep adding triples or
triple patterns to the list yeah no I
mean there's there's advantages to that
kind of thing okay look they I noticed
we have somebody who dropped in on our
live stream saying that they desperately
want this functionality I'm now going to
ask I'd be curious what for
because that's that sort of the
challenge that I'm seeing here is you
know there are very limited set of
people who have you know Sparkle
you know triples stored databases
effectively look I mean you know what is
clearly the case is that shipping this
some kind of package that people can use
is clearly a win the question is how
much effort should we go to to try and
integrate it properly I guess the next
thing is make it work on our own entity
stores yes
formulate a non-trivial community that
you can't formulate right now within the
entity pop of the world and make them
expressible smooth Sparkle select and
then apply them to an entity store right
and then ask the question what do we
imagine I mean you know one thing is
going from natural language to this yeah
another thing is going from some
sensible Wolfram language toys it's
basically just a wrapper around sparkle
yes like what would be our ideal both
one language girls and to do it right
well I think we started talking about
that in terms of graphed patterns yeah
we didn't finish that I mean we gave up
and said oh well let's I mean the reason
was that the graph pattern matching that
we can do is basically what the basic
crafts pattern stands for know it again
in the details section but all the other
things are hard to I am that is an
example of visualize visualizing graphs
so normally if you try to visualize
millions of edges or even billions you
won't see anything so this is one
approach to visualizing graphs by
showing what are the classes in debt in
your ontology and what are the
properties in which class classes they
link to and from so if you import some
random data set that you found an
Internet you can check how does it look
like wait a minute there aren't a lot of
random data sets on the internet because
there just aren't a lot of RDF things I
mean for example let's say I take your
fruit example from up above here right
which was is this the whole graph here
right so I take line 9 right so what I
want to do is take um can I literally
take line 9 Val graph yeah but it won't
show anything so it will be empty
why okay no you're right to come to it
but why is that because I haven't put
any effort developing debt ontology
nicely so I would declare okay what are
my entities what are my classes I don't
have any class relations and I haven't
declared what the properties are so it's
very experimental okay we take an
example live from something in wiki data
and visualize it
what is that entertain how do I get a
lump of the of the wiki data um graph so
you should be able to say import of that
IRI and get something back however you
have to specify a content type so that
it knows you are requesting let's say
turtle yeah what's I hope it's black so
this one is just some JSON but what we
want is some other form and you have to
some hotel
Vickey data that it needs to emit turtle
so this is not no that doesn't work
because we haven't said that content
types that is something that we have to
ok but so so what you're saying is that
wicked wiki data does not expose its
turtle unless you ask you get to is that
correct yes so what we can do is using
either writer wrapper alone and then use
something like URL execute and specified
accept header and say turtle or whatever
and then we would get an RDF graph that
describes that IRI
and then we can visualize it for
whatever
okay so we got a couple of interesting
examples from Michael Hale and Karl Lang
on the live stream here one is about car
data one is about Pope's and Cardinals
see both of those kinds of things like
car data for example we have done a huge
amount of work now to actually make I
have no idea what I don't even know any
types of tires
let's see um let's try that is that the
type of car I think that's the type of
car I the latter it's a type of turtle I
don't know why isn't that did I misspell
that cars are not yet exposed in
language so they're in wolf now for but
they're not exposed in language
so if I were to do that in
[Music]
so if I were to say the same thing
if I would say the same thing here that
I would see all kinds of information
that right what is our plan for exposing
Latin language I'd like to do it now
that we're documenting entity types it's
been a hard thing to tell people how to
use without having that documentation um
right I mean the problem is you know
it's I mean wiki dater is a much messier
business than what we end up having but
there are things that will be in wiki
data because they are messier than what
we have um you know I think so if if the
goal is you know just like we have
Wikipedia data you know if what people
actually want to do if the sole example
of RDF that people care about is wiki
data there's an argument that um you
know we should be doing something more
like what we do with Wikipedia data
which is you know nice and you know well
packaged for that particular purpose
like for example in this case obviously
we've got a mess here because we're you
know we didn't tell it to you know talk
turtle so to speak and they're making
sense yeah so I mean if we were to say
you know wiki data data effectively and
have that be a thing that allows people
to and what would we do just imagine
that we were doing that just imagine we
were exposing wiki data in some way what
would we want to expose around it so the
immediate thing that comes to my mind is
having a nice table like when you click
that IRI you will also see on the web so
we can show the same information but
that wouldn't be too useful because
people could also look that up on the
web the real power comes difficult like
complicated queries like No
well I understand that but the question
is are those queries being written and
sparkle or they bring with this in our
language why would they I mean the thing
is I think that it would be a lot more
powerful if we abstracted away from
Sparkle and like for example there are
ways of translating some of the sparkle
queries to SQL not necessarily
efficiently and there are other graph
languages graph query languages and so
okay let's understand the end points
here okay first point is there are
people who have Sparkle databases that
they want to make use of in our language
you know that is essentially you know an
import type story um you know that's
something where effectively we are you
know people want to be able to do a
better job than this of importing
something that comes from wiki data and
dealing with it in our language and if
part of that import has to do with um
the you know being able to run sparkle
queries against a sparkle database
before it comes into our language then
great you know it's the thing that's one
point is insofar as there is existing
Sparkle material out there in the world
rdf material whatever out there in the
world um you know we should let people
connect to it just like we let people
import JSON and XML and who knows what
else um
you know the next question is do we want
to make use of you know
do we want to actually have a you know
Sparkle stuff running within our
language for example do we want to make
our own entity stores you know
accessible or Sparkle endpoints I think
that's kind of pointless you know I
think that's some yes I know it depends
what you mean by this I think if you
have a collection of entity stores of
different types with connections in
between making them accessible as one
giant net with connections also then as
a set of products I feel like that's
that's very nice if we can make use of
that in our language and reasonable way
yes right but I mean that requires a
build-out of essentially you know and in
a language the expectations for what can
be done with graph matching are
definitely higher than what one would
expect in the pure Sparkle world and and
also I guess that our current built-in
entity you word looks still looks a lot
more like an SQL database so would it
make sense to expose entities as an SQL
database maybe probably the performance
would not be great now it is pointless I
mean it's it's some I feel like we have
put a lot of energy over the last years
to make property values entities if
there are not quantities which is kind
already a good canonical endpoint and
the more we do that the more we have in
principle a connection between zinc I'm
not in practice yeah but that's that's
that's something that it's very easy to
represent him in SQL we're not gonna use
SQL for that I mean it just doesn't okay
let's let's zoom out of it what we're
trying to achieve strategic play I mean
first point is to have this whole
package that Tony has developed be made
available to people seems like a fine
thing to do it is something deeply in
the world of sparkle and RDF triples and
so on and people who don't understand
those things aren't going to be able to
use it and that's okay
now the question is do we want to
promote it to something that people who
don't already know about RDF will be
capable of using yeah well that is a
whole separate issue yeah but can I try
to separate our two different questions
to RDF and sparkle RDF is a way to store
data and sparkle is a query language so
RDF is not particularly interesting per
se and many times can be built on top of
SQL mmm-hmm of classical databases
Sparkle is a lot more interesting and
it's not the sole player in time that
can do graph queries because it's
terrible to do things like transitive
closure on or in SQL so if you don't
know how many hops you need to do like
if you wanna ask a question like is X a
relative of Y in SQL it's almost
impossible I mean there are ways of
doing it but it's like understanding the
math it's crazy
so this is where I think we should take
the value of all this work and say how
do we in whether however are things
stored and whatever the query language
is how do we represent things that are
effectively transitive closure questions
yeah I think I know which is what we
were talking about before with graph
matching but somehow that got diverted
because why Tony I mean we were starting
to look at actual syntax for
representing paths and graphs and
patterns for paths and graphs why did we
divert from that yeah basically two
things first of all these RDF graphs are
hyper crafts and not the grass that we
have in the Wolfram language
but the other thing is that our Cole has
many more features that are not really
compatible this existing color matching
technology lets some queries so for dead
we would need an equivalent color
matching construct which is something
similar to grammar rules but for general
expressions and patterns
it's snow specifically what I mean but
look if we're going to integrate this
these are the kinds of problems we have
to solve and their comparatively
difficult and eventually we're going to
want to do this but you know from a
timing point of view the stuff that you
have here that is essentially a
compatibility bridge with the sparkle
world seems perfectly sensible is it is
it almost finished we can start writing
queries against existing sparking points
now working on some performance re is
working on getting some new importers
ready so they are fast enough but I
think we can pretty soon a first version
so we could have something analogous to
our xml functionality that is
as an import type functionality as that
right
that means without any of those symbols
I don't know I mean possibly in their
own context I mean what we've done with
XML which I don't consider to be totally
satisfactory is I mean you know we what
is it from 15 years ago or something
we've had the whole XML import um well
we have this whole XML element business
which is what you get out from doing an
XML import I don't consider it to be
super satisfactory I mean people
certainly use it but I don't think it's
you know the issue is XML is its own
world
somewhat with somewhat different
structure from generic expressions and
so on this is the same type of thing yes
actually XML element and the technology
is pretty useful I just wrote the RDF
XML import on top of XML element I think
we could improve certain area so element
yeah I don't disagree it's it's but I'm
saying that if you don't know XML you
know you don't care about XML element
it's not a general feature of the
language it's something specific as a
bridge to the XML world which is similar
to what you're doing here without EF yes
so I mean okay yes I know these take a
60% but none of the XML element you
could apply to go from generic word from
language expression to do things you
couldn't do otherwise which would be the
case for spark assets if you can convert
our stuff out to sparkle know if Puni
can do this under the hood so what will
be the case okay so look one example is
you're taking wiki data from the outside
you're representing it using these are
they have triple things whatever else
and then you're doing operations that
are you know nominally Wolfram language
operations but which basically require
an understanding of sparkle to be able
to use them so that's one case now
what's the other case you're describing
I was more thinking like why that's to
the way to go for writing a sparkle like
really still in this part of the world
and sparkle
sinteres attorney has but against say
our own visiting entities and how would
that work
I mean we would have some IRI that's
that's an exposure of our built-in
semantic relations framework so we would
need a correspondence between entities
and IR eyes and then the idea is that we
can use entities or hire eyes
interchangeably and entities lots of it
our eyes yeah right as the object here
just like yes yes we could use an entity
property there or even an IRI that
stands for the entity Barberie basically
interchangeably however they use of
prefers yeah but we don't have IR eyes
we don't have not defined eye our eyes
for our entities we certainly we've
considered we we actually have done that
a decade ago almost we did something
like that and then decided we didn't
want it um but but in this case there's
a pretty naturally translation between
the left
IRA as entity the middle AI as a
property and the right one as a property
value sure yeah we could be smart enough
to recognize this for instance
one proposal is if you enter an entity
in both from alpha you usually get
information about that entity so D both
from alpha address is in some sense a
natural IR entity that's what we one of
the things we've built a long time ago
right I don't know okay again look this
this project you know what do we think
is the big payoff from this project
I think the big payoff is we have at
least a working underlying
implementation for a potential future or
much more complicated query language
against our entity framework okay even
if you don't have yet the top-level
language to express it fair enough okay
but so look that it seems like the steps
that need to be gone through are one
package this up so that it can be used
by people who have existing you know
Sparkle endpoints and so on there is a
question that needs to be addressed as
to whether this is all in the system
context and whether we actually have
things like sparkles select in the
system context I think for now we put it
in their own context for for playing
around I tend to agree with that I mean
that's now for XML I think that's what
we initially did and then years ago we
took it out and put it in the system
context um what is this question mark
syntax doing what is that so this is
actually in full form is it Sparkle
variable and then a string name in this
case int and this is too verbose so
we've made a nice formatting that is
similar to the sparkle formatting oh boy
the
of course must be all change for the
language there's no question what the
heck is that
full form oh yeah so it's some kind of
oh my gosh because some months ago we
still use just naked symbols for
variables and it was not nice
so this yeah well I this syntax I mean
it's not title belen I you know it's not
you know we can have some kind of print
form for these things you know for an
audio trouble I mean this is not very
consistent you know this is not a good
idea we should not do this here you know
for entering the thing it should be if
it's Sparkle variable that's what it
should be and in terms of a print form
for this collection you know for the
audio if triple and so on you can have
whatever print form you want you can
never be perfectly beautiful and not
have a you know quotes P etcetera
etcetera why are there two elements in
these IR eyes so this is a namespace and
the identifier in that namespace
it's shorter than writing out the whole
fire I one thing I was thinking is that
we kind of had a similar problem with
templates lot and I guess Tony you have
a parser for force powerful yes and so
maybe what you could do is like just
just let people write sparkle and then
an umbrella it's what we do I mean in
the case of regular expression right we
let people write pure reg X strings if
they want basic example that you see on
the screen here yeah but we don't have a
reg X s parser that can turn the Reg
accent or string expression in this case
we do right so you can then reason about
it like when and manipulate it
symbolically and the same goes for for a
string template or XML template all that
stuff you can type in HTML instead of
XML elements because it's faster and
then parse that and that into xml
elements
one question about the sparkle variable
the formatting so if you check quantity
variable it also has a formatting
alright but that's something that's
deeply built into the language and
supported all over the place this is not
this is something which is basically you
know some bizarre variant of our
built-in pattern variables that because
sparkle doesn't happen to support our
built in pattern variables we have to do
it differently and it should not be
something that is you know a I mean we
could have had this syntax 30 years ago
to represent something we don't you know
let's not introduce it as some weird
Sparkle variable thing
and you know it should be it should be
entered like this um well users enter it
like this but later if you hit shift
enter informants like that so that's how
I entered it okay but this isn't okay
fine whatever I mean I use a wooden type
question mark okay fair enough okay
let's let's big a picture what is it
going to take to get this to be usable
as a package in its own context in some
kind of sparkle context with all these
symbols in that sparkle context is this
sparkle the right name for the context
so this graph store project how we call
it right now it has basically at least
three components one is IRI which is
completely independent then there's RDF
and then there's part two which builds
on top of RDF so it's basically three
things that we somehow group into some
context currently craft store but
potentially in the future that could be
support fodder graph language just so
I'm wondering it should be generic like
grass store or something more specific I
think if we're going to have these kinds
of functions then it should be specific
because basically this stuff will not be
usable except by people who understand
sparkle and we're not trying to make it
usable by anybody else you know we were
trying to do that we would actually
build it into our language with our own
mechanism and it wouldn't be called RDF
triple am I making sense
you know we would have something that's
cold I don't know I mean didn't we
didn't we start the design that had
things that weren't you know rdf branded
ways of representing relations yes but
we talked with charles okay
so we've gone backwards is basically
what you're telling me i mean last time
we talked about this which was like two
months ago we were much further ahead on
figuring out how we could actually
integrate it this with the language
we've basically revert reverted to
something which is a thin wrapper around
sparkle
is that a true statement it's actually
the nicely designed symbolic language
for Sparkletts not just a wrapper but
fair enough
I'm not attacking that do I need to go
look at my notes from this from before
the I think I look at my notes from
before I mean we don't have much
infrastructure for anything else in the
coughs that we have had now the dank
retreat all pretty simple
absolutely so the real power of the
language comes out when you write non
trivial things like I'm working on -
Sparkle based projects now and using the
symbolic form is so useful especially
when you let somebody form you you mean
this form like audio yes if you write
they have to write queries or construct
queries recursively that would be
nightmare using strain joins sure it's
really convenient and it saves a lot of
work having that symbolic form right but
that has nothing to do with whether you
represent it was question mark blah oh
yes in code you don't see this question
mark you just write spot a variable
right okay but so so just to be clear
you know what we could be doing is
trying to make action pass okay first of
all we've got okay so what are the steps
we've got hypergraphs instead of graphs
yeah and we've got graph patterns which
we don't have right now
right now we have patterns for trees but
not for graphs right yeah mostly and
then be sure to be must coordinate the
whole thing Chris Martin smirks with
what they did of the chemical basis they
paid on equivalent yeah exactly which is
which is then patterns for pieces of
chemicals yes coit which are graphs not
hyper graphs right good question Smart's
our crafts milk say for Hyper cough
elements what else milks for in for
chemical reactions where you have mood
sings in and moveable things out yeah
okay all right so what are we trying to
decide in this meeting
I think one of the bigger question was
the context and the design of the
language that overall so so far we had
some people internally use Sparkle and
rdf but we still have to look over all
the names at least some of them and some
ref pages okay what tack is an audio
data set that's yet another new thing
yes if that's the most general form so
you can generate some documentation page
for that yeah I can send it in a moment
how many symbols are there in your in
your design here currently 39 oh my gosh
but if we put them in own context it's
not such a big deal no it's not but I
mean this is a giant sparkle subsystem
basically which is oh boy okay all right
well look so given what you just said
there is no question these things are
going in their own context
then the question is okay so we do that
we try and make something where wiki
data in particular is easy to access
that way we then try to start
potentially exposing some of our
internal you know entity structure to
the system do we understand how to do
that or not I'm working on it it's a
two-step process the first step is
support for our to our ml which means
using sparkle to query relational
databases and dead one is achieved by
using a mapping language in which to
express how the relational database maps
to end it them to sparkle Vanguardia and
once we know that we can build on top of
that to define a language or as simple
syntax to define how to map entities to
RDF and using that mapping we can then
write sparkle queries against entities I
have something a talk but I like to
improve that a little bit
hmmm I think we need to talk about this
project some more um the I mean I think
um I you know basically as its own world
of sparkle stuff I'm sure you've done a
nice job mapping sort of sparkle into a
symbolic form but this is far away from
having something that's properly
integrated and you know maybe we don't
care at this point to have something
that's properly integrated maybe it
doesn't matter because maybe what the
main use is people who already have
Sparkle stuff maybe we find some way to
expose our stuff yeah I I mean Michael
but how much I mean this is yeah the key
question is there's no question that for
practical purposes what people are
starts right now our entity property
factorization covers 94 be covered 90%
mm-hmm so
but we are not be able to formulate a
better complicated queries against our
knowledgebase
I know so this is cool it just but in
order to get to the point where we can
formulate those queries in an integrated
way we need to build out a bunch of
other stuff that's not obvious
yeah well the depends of course always
on the level but if you look at this so
the first one as we already discussed
would be some kind of smart
identification of our eyes were also its
entities entity properties and this was
against quantities and other things so
then we would need a notion of RDF table
which probably should have anyway like
right now you have an entity of a
poverty and if the result of the end of
the property value but we don't have a
nice container for the whole thing which
say with before spoken assault anyway
the most natural representation of to
think yes other than you visit you'll
say well I mean but there's one thing is
to represent that enter the property
value thing which we effectively have
some kind of representation for in an
entity store yes inside but not as fun
but one thing like we don't have a
representation of the population of
Tokyo is 9.8 million people we do not
but but then once we have that you know
yes then we can make those pieces of
that into pattern variables exactly that
we make pieces independent variable and
we collect a few of them and NVR feel
like not too far away from a reasonable
nice query language yeah right but the
way that would look as we discussed ages
ago but it is something more like I mean
right now what we will be saying so
let's imagine that we had something that
said something like entity query okay
and which is something against our
entity store and it was you know entity
query and let's say I'm just going to
make a you know entity assertion let's
say let's say that that's what it is
and the entity assertion is that you
know entity property value basically and
so then this would be something like or
actually what this would be is entity
cases something like this a bunch of
entity assertions some of which have
pattern variables in them I mean is this
that this is not the most general form
by any means you know we don't just want
to get a couple entities back we want to
get a fragment of purple beach
properties which little eyes which
entities yeah I mean this is exactly the
stuff that Sparkle has been built to be
able to do all right but you know
merging that with the kinds of things
that we're able to do I mean yes it's
this light we could say let's turn all
our pattern matching into regular
expressions well that won't work right
regular expressions can do certain set
of things it's a you know it's mostly a
subset of what we can do there are some
things right regular expressions can do
which we've never cared to do in our you
know symbolic expression
pattern-matching and it hasn't come up
in 30 years so it's kind of like we
probably shouldn't worry about it but it
happens to be a thing that some kind of
weird you know look-back mechanism for
reggae X's that got implemented a few
times similarly here you know there are
things that people really want to do and
there are probably ornate things that
people actually don't care very much
about doing and you know the question is
can we make a design that actually fits
in with the you know full power of our
pattern language and can deal with
essentially this graph fragment matching
stuff that exists here and that is a
complicated project which it sounds like
we were on a path to talk about a few
months ago and that seems to have been
derailed from what I'm understanding
that right
say it I would say first we follow it
one existing one to have something and
then we can go back and make something
that fits fully our language I think
that there is some confusion here like
what you were saying that we need to
have some way of representing triples to
be able to graph queries and that's not
true I mean you can you can have it in a
pattern language without having it for
storage like it's just a matter of
whether you stored the adjacency list or
you store the graph in some other way
no nobody speaks about stores we only
speak about the representation of the
query yeah when you write and like okay
look right now we have a mechanism I
mean if we want to know you know what
country has a population how would we do
this we got a population nearest to five
million right so we would say you know
something like this which is kind of a
you know what would it be nearest to and
then what would I say five million here
you know five million people and do I
have do it how do I have to have nearest
things I want all that work I still
think it's weird that what comes out
here still requires an entity list great
well that didn't work
what did that just do what did that just
do when you run you take care of that
but that's still shouldn't evaluate you
cannot run into these fundamentally it's
one NP no useful for do you think that
will work what was the bug in one end to
do like the heavy duty class anyways
yeah what what should I do here one one
nine up yeah well this is the same you
know this is where we should be spending
effort to get it fixed
No
still not working so what did I do wrong
do I have to say five million people
here yes okay so if I say they're comic
ten or something then I should get so
why is no way not oh I see these are the
things between if I say entity value of
that population what I should see is
those things being around five million
okay fair enough
um okay now what would happen if I
wanted to know the population in 1970
being closest to five million can I do
that here you what dated around
population it's really annoying but I
have to say entity list every time here
any shooting me but why do we need it
because you asked for a class to get it
close you didn't ask for a list why
would you want to ever see the mist like
like why don't she would if I say here
entity list will that work know what I'm
saying that if you take the entity class
and just before ask for say name like
apply until value to you can get Li and
population same time just just think the
end the class and apply to it you know
entity coma yeah you don't need to see
the single entities ever think I mean
the entity facilities are not meaningful
like what is the meaning what should I
want I want to know yeah that's really
what is what is the me and that only
happens to be the print form of that but
every what you really want is the me
mobile I want to say the print form
because I think that's what's useful but
but Steven this is because in this case
it's a few if it would be ten to the six
you don't want to see them so that's
correct
yeah what I'm seeing is in general we're
like with this pattern of having the
single entities do something we're like
we're educating people to do things
always in two steps and that's wrong I
mean this case doesn't matter because
the population of Norway hasn't changed
significantly between the two queries
but in general you you want to educate
people to always do things in one go
okay that's a separate issue
I mean look honestly putting more effort
into getting this stuff to be smooth
seems to me a lot more important than
this you know kind of tentacle of
sparkle stuff and you know well anyway
look I think we probably have to wrap
this discussion up you know
let's package the sparkle stuff to be
its own separate context thing um I
don't know how much design effort should
be put into it
given you know for example it's not
clear how much I can help with this
because I'm not a big Sparkle expert we
were discussing ages ago you know making
sure we've talked to a bunch of what the
heck is all this stuff what is this what
is sparkle us so there are different
query forms one of them is Sparkle
select get us what to ask that just
takes just a pattern exists and then
just what does that have to do with the
ask function in our language unrelated
really well why is it given this name
it's following the sparkle standard so
we're basically just building a wrap or
a wrapper around sparkle here which is
what I keep on saying you know the word
select happens to be similar to our
select but that's purely coincidental
it's not that similar actually yes but
having two functionality at our disposal
not the name by agree I agree so I think
you know in the theory that the only
people who can use this for people who
know sparkle then it's a fine thing to
use
names that they are familiar with and
you know given that just put it in the
Sparkle context now how do you get it to
return something that connects to the
rest of the system what do you mean well
okay so at the end what's it gonna
return that can be connected to the rest
of the system it might be some list of
entities or something that is yes so in
general you get back nodes which are ice
but there's a special case called
literals and they are xml literals and
they map to our let's say dates like in
this case and some literals they don't
map to anything like what so users are
free to define their own literals and
there's no way we can know what they
meant so it's their job to process them
however they like so this is very
general yeah I mean listen you should be
putting more effort into making sure
that entity still works smoothly that it
maps into the you know the database
stuff that there aren't bugs like though
me just found here and so on you know
those are mainline things this to me is
kind of more of an experiment
I mean I thought it might turn it
something other than that but it really
isn't it's really a sparkle experiment
right now which is fine um so let's get
it finished and let's get it put in a
sparkle context with things which are
admittedly Sparkle type functionality
and you know just like we are doing you
know the [ __ ] link thing this is a
similar kind of thing where the [ __ ]
link thing is very you know visibly
[ __ ] oriented so to speak and you know
what we're doing with SQL is much more
deeply integrated and it's not you know
full of SQL language so to speak so in
the databases there's this prefix it's
not called SQL but databases at least
one of the layers that I've seen they
also have like aggregation and I'm
wondering shall we review that let's say
the aggregate operator that they are
aligned or no I mean it's not gonna work
look you know the effort to align what
we're doing here between you know look
we either have to say this design is
based on a sparkle design all we have to
say we're actually going to make our own
real design
okay we're not making our own real
design that's a lot more work you're
basically making something that is
leveraging the sparkle design which is
fine it's just not something that you
know can be deeply integrated it's
perfectly useful in the underlying
technology can be reused in a futile
design that is ours right which is fine
and we've done that many times before
but you know we shouldn't try to make it
some kind of compromise where we're
trying to you know and we certainly
shouldn't do things which look like
they're you know making some major
change of syntax to support some weird
Sparkle variable thing you know do the
best job we can in the sparkle context
for all of these kinds of things and
let's get that put in as quickly as we
can can we get that version 12 then
we'll Debbie well the next month or so
it should be possible okay not perfect
but well that's okay we can tag it as
experimental and in its own context yes
and then people can use it including us
and then we can slowly start
experimenting I mean as you say like
like the XML stuff I don't consider that
that was adequately designed 15 years
ago or something right but as you say
it's still perfectly useful if you're
prepared to you know you know dive deep
into the XML world right but but people
who are not XML experts are not going to
be able to use it except in a very
stylized way in that particular case and
I think the same will be true here which
is fine um
so what else do we have to figure out
about this now my statement is yes why
don't you have it map closely to the
sparkle design don't try to make too
many you know don't try to have
compromises where you're trying to map
it into our design you know and remove
functionality that would be Sparkle
functionality because it isn't worth it
it's it's something for you know for
people who already know sparkle make
sense yes so it's a complete
implementation of sparkle 1.1 the latest
standard so it's passing all the
official tests magnificent but it's
basically our binding for that using a
symbolic language yeah it was pretty
tricky to design it at least until this
stage you know even so it doesn't seem
might not seem like it but there were
some very tricky questions how to map
certain things into a way that looks a
little bit more from language like using
function composition to have a sparkle
query and then an aggregation they are
using function composition and that
looks a little bit different than
sparkle or pretty different depending on
how you look at it well do you like the
way it works with function composition
yes it's pretty natural how you see the
pipe like first you start with the
Select then you have some solutions and
then you could continue transforming
that solution and then you can apply
another application and another and so
on
sighs look I mean it seems like with
with considerable effort you've sold one
to these problems the problem you
haven't solved which is a you know
frankly I think is a year-long design
process is getting this thing to really
map into you know it's it's it's a it's
a big complicated process that involves
us implementing hypergraphs and having
you know graph patterns and so on which
we want to have quite separate from this
and perhaps what we should be doing
partly in connection with chemistry
partly in connection with other things
is starting off by having patterns in
ordinary graphs forget the hyper graphs
aspect of it um it would be definitely
to feel step right which is its own
separate you know year-long process
probably um it is no until the
implementation issues sure I know I know
we implemented that like 20 years ago
for these you know space-time graph
things that that I've occasionally
worked on you know we had a good
implementation that worked for you know
for hundreds of millions of nodes and so
on for certain specialized cases but
yeah it's non-trivial um okay what else
do we anything else we need to figure
out here I mean
you know the question of the review of
the design of the 39 symbols that you're
talking about being in the Sparkle
context um let's see a guide page for
that um and again that guide page should
refer directly into the sparkle you know
your Sparkle 1.1 standard and so on
and should just say this is essentially
a binding wrapper whatever you want to
call it symbolic representation yes yeah
because I think that's what you know
people will understand that you can use
that it's all good but we want to
pretend that it's our own integrated
thing yes so I studied sweet guide pages
one about RDF one about sparkle query
and one about sparkle update what
sparkle update so it's the update
language so you can query or you can
modify an RDF graph oh my gosh okay and
that's part of the thirty-nine symbol so
that's another eighteen it's part
everything thirty-nine okay all right
okay um okay but so now what is the what
is our ability to maintain our own
sparkle database or are we mostly
pre-existing ones internally we already
have some running and they are used
internally at least by Aaron I know I
don't know who else okay but so are we
planning to actually host those
ourselves in the cloud are we planning
to have individual users host them I
think user can just set up their own
sparkle endpoint and make it accessible
under a URL it's up to them to find one
product that they like oh wait a second
wait a second wait a second wait a
second that's a whole separate thing are
we going to let them set up a sparkle
database that runs in using our Sparkle
package or are we gonna say oh you're on
your own build your own server and then
you can use our stuff to interact with
that I think we haven't thought about
this yet yeah we haven't but but the
process would be something like you run
one line on the command line to start
depth
Parker ran that's not gonna work so as
its as a demon type thing I think Tony
and Steven you speak right now about
differences okay explain I think Tony is
speaking this infant session and you
mean it as something permanent well I
don't know I don't know what what Tony
what do you mean are you talking about a
sort of pop-up sparkle database that
exists only within the the scope of one
Wolfram language session are you talking
about something that's a permanent thing
like a permanent database yeah it's
something that the user can run on their
machine or their server and then they
use spar to update to load a file or to
insert some triples manually where does
it live
I mean is it in the local object store
is it in some random directory that
would be independent of store from
language but it's not if we okay can you
create it from Wolfram language or is it
something that has to pre-exists it's
it's something like a sequel database
that you have to set up somewhere okay
so right there we just reduced the
number of people who can use this by
another huge factor but it's no it's
it's setting up some whole thing with
system administration etc etc etc
permissions and so on it's complicated
yes if you make it public yes right so
and then the next question is does it
run in the cloud you know do we how does
it work with our cloud sandbox for
example s8 we
thought about this you know you'd also
fall okay but so okay
so just to be clear the scenario you
have thought about is there is a
pre-existing Sparkle database somewhere
Sparkle endpoint external to us and you
are importing things from it like the
wiki data case or you've gone through a
lot of effort you've mirrored that thing
you've got a whole setup you've got
system administration around it etc etc
etc those are the cases that you've
considered so far is that right
oh how to view our own worlds hood
sparking clauses okay but that's not the
same as the sparkle update thing that
was just dropped on us
yeah that's a completely different thing
that's a story I mean that's something
we have not reached in the SQL world in
in the in you know our entity store
mechanism in the SQL world we're not
doing updates there right not for
version 1 but we're planning to
implement them later I understand that
but but as soon as we're doing updates
there's a whole complicated set of
authentication issues and locking issues
and you know synchronization and so on
yes how does that work for these Sparkle
things and that's up to implementation
of the triple store which we're not
doing and how do we pass through the
authentication information to that
server it can be included in the URL or
in HTTP requests so in other words we
have to build something that gateways
through our authentication mechanism
because it could be in you know in the
headers and the HTTP headers it could be
in the you know username and password
could be in in shockingly bad security
in the actual URL and so on is that
right yeah basically like any API right
but then we've got both to implement etc
etcetera etcetera if that's really how
that's going to work this is complicated
very complicated and not obviously
worthwhile yeah so I mean I think we'd
better see a list of the 39 symbols um
let's get that look why don't you start
okay
the path were on very soon is implement
this as a separate package with its own
context that will be tagged as
experimental and try to get it into
version 12 it's the future I stare FHS
and make them experimental no you should
put them as a package ref pages in a
package right you know how to do that
yes basically in the
texts right yeah I'm not I actually
don't remember how you do that but it's
the same way that database link works
and [ __ ] link and all those kinds of
things
yes exactly um right they um yeah okay
okay so look I think we're on that path
we should understand you know a nice
smooth way to get wiki data into this as
an example right that doesn't involve
import that you know doesn't know how to
talk turtle so to speak yes so then
would basically be a function like
entity value right so you have entire I
and then you ask for properties you ask
for a data set right I would think so
and maybe what we need there is
something that is purely a different
kind of function like Wikipedia data
that works on wiki data if that's coming
back as something which isn't even
related to sparkle particularly but that
might be a useful thing to have anyway I
mean maybe I would like to comment on
discussion in urine and how would we
call such a function iri information or
i don't think so i think it would be
like wiki data well wiki data data it's
an unfortunate name but but that concept
meeting before we discussed this with
ellen in your honor among okay but i
mean that's something that doesn't
really require it requires just this
turtle importer it doesn't really
require the whole structure of this
whole sparkle query system right or am i
what you get back is an RDF graph and
then you query juicing Sparkle if you
just want the actual data to be useful
yeah you can write a trivial query in
sparkle just give me no parity you and
sparkle is not achievable by most of our
users right there's a different class of
people that know sparkle and can write
sparkle queries from the class of people
who just want to extract stuff from wiki
data for example understand the problem
but I don't think any of us any doesn't
fair enough um okay well look the the
you know I I know this has been a
somewhat long road getting this sparkle
integration to work and you know no it's
I mean we've certainly been talking
about it for more than a year um you
know it's exciting to see it actually
come to fruition even though I don't
appreciate it as much as I might because
I'm not enough of a sparkle expert um
but okay I think we're on a path get
this documentation in a separate context
for a separate package tagged as
experimental and I I would think that
you guys can review it without me and
I'd like to see it again once you have
it in the form of you know a bunch of
guide pages and so on and I you know
honestly I'm not going to be able to do
that deeper review because I just don't
know this subject area well enough um
and I think you know then after version
12 is when you get to start
experimenting with using these kinds of
things on our entity store right yes
that's all right so I have 39 guide
pages even if it's minimal it's rough
pages all correct registry guide pages
and
that means today I experimental I sit so
to say yup and put them in their own
package yes and and you know and get
please get rid of some of these weird
things about you know that are you know
that like masquerade as being new syntax
and so on
okay um okay sounds great
okay thank you might see you soon okay
thanks to people with comments on the
livestream